okay okay people let's bring up the fog
a little bit more a little bit more yeah
yeah ah perfect queue em up let's see
here
good good excellent you will be missed
good whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa hey excuse me what is this is
there a problem yeah there's a problem
what are the stage directions say for
this cold open several holograms of dead
celebrities dead celebrities who's this
will smith uh-huh it is will smith dead
are you actually asking or no no he's
not he is not dead
just figure it out we'll find someone
else to fill the slot oh sir just check
the manifest that's not actually a
hologram of will smith no no that is a
hologram of will smith's career it just
died well ain't that just a slap in the
face
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory
where we encourage you to slap that
subscribe button harder than you would
an award show host making ball jokes so
a couple weeks ago we started examining
disney's use of deep fake and digital d
aging technology in the wake of young
luke appearing all over the book of boba
fett during that discussion we briefly
touched on the fact that more and more
studios seem to be bringing characters
played by actors who've died back into
their films played by the actors who've
already died ranging from paul walker
and fast and furious you can leave
without saying goodbye to carrie fisher
and star wars and harold ramus and
ghostbusters i thought you might turn up
but of them one stood out from the
others a digital peter cushing played
grand moff tarkin in 2016's rogue one
you see peter cushing died back in 1994
so his appearance in rogue one wasn't
like some sort of respectful send-off to
a recently departed actor plus they've
gotten other actors to play tarkin in
the past like in revenge of the sith
even the body double they got to perform
the character in rogue one looks enough
like tarkin that they didn't need to go
all digital necromancer for the scene
see something about this got my fierce
senses tingling disney doesn't usually
do something unless there's a business
advantage in doing it and this seemed
like more than just a pr move so i
started digging and from what i found i
think disney is playing a long game when
it comes to deceased actors by seating
the idea of reviving characters now they
stand to earn some big money in the
ownership and employment of dead actors
decades from now let me explain you see
indie studio magic city films made
headlines back in 2019 when they
announced that they were working on an
adaptation of the novel finding jack the
story of a vietnam vet finding his will
to live after rescuing a wounded dog the
story itself wasn't the thing that made
headlines obviously instead it was who
was cast as the leading man james dean
now if you don't know who james dean is
i can't really blame you at this point
dean was a hollywood heartthrob most
known for his role in rebel without a
cause but his rise to stardom was cut
tragically short in 1955 when he died in
a car crash at the age of 24 and now you
start to see why this movie caught
people's attention he died nearly 70
years ago and yet he's about to star in
a brand new movie see the filmmakers
plan to revive dean using the same
mixture of cgi body double and face
swapping that we've seen used to create
tarkin in rogue one and young luke in
the mandalorian the plan was met with
immediate backlash but still it merits
the question are they allowed to do
something like this legally and that got
me asking the even bigger question who
actually owns a dead celebrity who can
and can't use the names and likenesses
of famous people in their movies tv
shows and advertisements for chicken
sandwiches and then i went to
chick-fil-a and got the new egg white
grill you know how many likes i'm gonna
get on this one so many likes call it a
guess but something tells me deceased
aviator amelia earhart never went to a
chick-fil-a and yet there's her name
right there chillin for breakfast
sandwiches so what gives well the short
answer is it's complicated there are
literally entire businesses dedicated to
selling the rights to use dead
celebrities like james dean and some
companies like disney are even building
libraries of their movie stars
potentially to keep the characters alive
long after the actors die yeah this is
one of those dark future episodes so
strap in loyal theorists today we're
taking a look at the dark digitally
altered dystopia that is celebrities the
business of dead celebrities yep
deliberately that is the official name
that the industry has given it hoo boys
is it gonna be a weird one so let's
start with a question that should have
itself an obvious answer do you own your
face yes you do but also
no you really don't you see according to
the justice systems of most countries
the person owns their body which
obviously includes your physical face
but what you don't necessarily own is
your image the representation of your
face according to most laws regarding
this the image of a person is considered
separate from the actual person
themselves so a drawing a painting a
photograph a video a statue heck even a
sculpture made out of butter all of that
is not considered the same as the person
who's the subject of said photo video or
butter sculpture the owner of those
creations is the person who created it
or the one who paid for it to be created
fun fact by the way the person who
created it part of the law actually
became subject of controversy in the mid
20 teens when a wildlife photographer
named david slater set up a camera in
indonesia that a macaque monkey named
naruto then used to take a series of
selfies yep this is a very real legal
case i guess naruto here was posing for
his hikage sculpture believe it several
websites then started using the selfies
without crediting or compensating slater
under the excuse that naruto the monkey
was the one who took the pictures and
was not considered a legal person
therefore could not hold copyright this
case actually got so much attention that
the u.s copyright office had to make an
official statement clarifying that the
photos were indeed in the public domain
free for anyone to use because they were
taken by a monkey all that monkey
business aside just because you don't
own your image doesn't mean they have
zero control over the use of your image
it's just that it's typically been
settled on a case-by-case basis for
example we all have a right to privacy
which protects us from having our image
taken without our consent in a private
space basically someone can't just put
up a camera against your window snap
some photos and call it an art piece
that is creepy and also super illegal
similarly states like california and
virginia have outlawed the use of deep
fakes to create intimate videos of
someone without their consent you're
also protected in cases of defamation
someone can't just take your image and
edit it into a context that would
seriously damage your reputation even
jay jonah jameson doesn't mess around
with that one that's slander it is not i
resent that slander is spoken in print
it's liable however the most relevant
piece of legalese that i want to look at
today is actually one that we briefly
talked about in part one of the series
the right of publicity in case you don't
remember the right of publicity protects
an individual's likeness and sometimes
their name voice and signature from
being used to promote a product without
their consent for example it's illegal
to use a picture of barack obama or
britney spears or internet weirdo matt
patton anything that implies they
endorse something that they haven't
already signed off on and that makes a
lot of sense right coca-cola can't use
me to promote regular coke when diet
coke is the far superior beverage it
would be a misuse of me my opinion and
my image but the extent of that
protection suddenly becomes murky when
it comes to the ability to raise dead
celebrities from beyond the grave you
see it ultimately depends on where you
are and how long the celebrity's been
dead most states recognize it for
somewhere between 50 and 100 years in
california where the biggest movie
studios are headquartered it exists for
70 years after death huh what a
coincidence that james dean died almost
70 years ago interestingly in tennessee
elvis's estate was actually able to
extend the right of publicity into
perpetuity so the king will reign
forever in nashville so who then owns
the dead celebrities during this
postmortem period their families and
their estates and that can be some big
business according to the 2021 forbes
list of highest earning dead celebrities
which is a thing that comes out every
year author roald dahl came in on top
earning a whopping 513 million dollars
when his estate sold away their shares
and his stories to netflix the prince
estate did largely the same thing with
prince's music last year earning
themselves 120 million as you might
expect a lot of musicians top the list
like michael jackson and juice world all
up there even sports athletes can crack
the top 10. among the list of singers
and authors is arnold palmer famous
golfer who died back in 2016. he earned
himself 27 million dollars off of
advertising and sales of his signature
lemonade iced tea mix now this sort of
thing isn't necessarily a new phenomenon
or a new business model merchandising
the likeness of dead celebrities in one
way or another has been a thing for
decades at big licensing conventions
there are whole booths dedicated to
single celebrities like cowboy john
wayne or iconic dracula bella lugosi
each hawking their likeness for whatever
the next big payday is what's it like
running the lugosi brand it's an honor
to preserve the memory of my grandfather
and extend his legacy into the future we
have a beautiful wine beer t-shirts
accessories collectible figures statues
that's how you get stuff like we talked
about last time fred astaire dancing
with a dirt devil or audrey hepburn
chillin for chocolate but what's changed
is the how of this business see not
every dead celebrity's family or estate
is gonna have the desire or the means to
make new business deals over the decades
and decades that they'll hold the image
rights to their deceased relative so it
only makes sense that some sort of
business would materialize to handle
that for them and not only that but in a
world where ip is king it makes sense
for those businesses to condense into
larger companies and guess what that is
already what's happening right now meet
companies like worldwide xr an ip
licensing company in production studio
formed in 2019 looking through their
website they seem to function like a
talent agency except they're a talent
agency for the dead the products that
they're licensing aren't brands they're
people worldwide claims to either own or
have exclusive deals with the families
estates and rights holders of the
likenesses of over 400 dead celebrities
and they've worked with huge companies
like apple google sony and mcdonald's if
you head on over to their website they
even have a nice clean catalog of all
the dead people you can license for your
movies and ads including famous faces
like burt reynolds andre the giant maya
angelou malcolm x neil armstrong rosa
parks and would you look at that james
dean yep worldwide xr's predecessor cmg
worldwide was the company that helped
coordinate the finding jack adaptation
that started me down this rabbit hole in
the first place so just to wrap things
up here in a nice little bow who owns
dead celebrities it depends mostly on
where you are and how long they've been
dead if you're in a us jurisdiction with
right of publicity laws that extend
after death the image of a dead
celebrity is owned by their family or
estate for up to 100 years after they've
died they can then license out that
celebrity's image for any number of
things for vacuum ads for tv cameos and
yes even leading roles in feature films
but here's where things start to get
tricky what happens after the rites of
publicity expire as i noted earlier
james dean died nearly 70 years ago
couldn't magic city films wait a few
more years to insert a digital zombie of
dean into their movies and not have to
pay a penny for it heck could i
resurrect james dean to co-host the show
historically this sort of concern has
never been a problem while someone's
right to publicity may lapse the
copyright for images of them are in
effect for a much longer period the life
of the author plus 70 years for instance
as we've discussed james dean's right to
publicity expires 70 years after his
death in 1955 so that would be 2025 just
three years from now but most of the
pictures of james dean were taken by a
man named dennis stock since he's the
owner of those images it means that the
copyright is tied to his life and
considering dennis stock died in 2010
dean's most iconic pictures enter public
domain for use in 2080 a full 55 years
after dean's likeness becomes available
and since there's never been a way to
exploit a dead actor that doesn't
involve pictures or video of them well
that's just really how long you had to
wait but now we've got deep fake
technology we're feeding libraries of
images and videos into computers to
produce living breathing talking
resurrections of actors and legally it
falls into an area that is so new that
the law has to the best of our research
never once considered as it sits right
now theoretically there doesn't seem to
be anything stopping me from creating a
lifelike render of james dean in three
years and using him to host the show or
star in my next movie or whatever and
the copyrights for the original images
that i'm feeding into the machine to
produce my james dean bot don't seem to
matter either at least they don't seem
to matter to disney in the behind the
scenes documentary for the mandalorian
the visual effects artist for ilm
admitted that they had searched the
internet for any and all high quality
interviews that they could find of mark
hamill from the 80s there was a moment
where i even scoured the internet and
found older interviews in that of of
mark hamill makes me feel good that
disney basically does the same thing
that our editors do for this show to
pull our assets anyway if those teams
over at disney use that footage in their
deep fakes they sure didn't credit any
of the interviews they used believe me i
checked sat through the mandalorians
credits and read every single name
nothing in short as people die and their
right to publicity expires starting to
look like you could create an archive of
famous actors all used for free all
waiting in their refrigerated
underground robot bunker or computer
server but i think underground bunker's
the cooler image waiting to be rolled
out to chill for the latest vacuum
cleaner and chocolate bar the only thing
that could possibly protect him at this
point is trademark maybe but right now
it all hinges on one woman marilyn
monroe marilyn monroe was the it girl of
hollywood back in the 50s and early 60s
she was a pop icon and sex symbol the
definition of the blonde bombshell the
woman who single-handedly redefined what
celebrity meant with iconic movies like
gentlemen prefer blondes and some like
it hot and like james dean she too died
prematurely at the age of 36. but what
makes her important in this discussion
is that though she died in los angeles
california she was a resident of the
state of new york at the time a state
that historically didn't have any right
to publicity protections that meant that
as soon as she tragically passed away it
was open season on the usage of her
likeness so her estate turned to
trademarks trademarking her name in
order to protect the marilyn monroe
brand and at this point it's something
that most celebrities are doing to
ensure extra safeguards around their
business justin bieber rihanna kim
kardashian all of them trademarked
speaking of the kardashians kylie
kardashian actually had a lot of
problems registering various trademarks
around her name because other people
beat her to the punch a clothing
trademark named kylie and kylie minogue
contesting the name kylie cosmetics the
kardashians eventually won both of those
because of course they did but you know
anyway marilyn monroe had the same
protection but in 2017 the trademark was
contested as being too generic after all
how can you possibly trademark just a
name so after two years of back and
forth in 2019 a judge ruled that the
trademark still stood but also didn't
rule on the nuances of the case what the
actual extent of those protections are
so nuances of the case are still being
hammered out we'll see so what does all
of this mean for my new movie starring
the deliberately marilyn monroe well
because the law hasn't caught up to
modern technology it should mean that i
can use her image and her voice in a
film without problem and without needing
to compensate anyone the only thing that
i can't explicitly do is use her name
therefore i present to you gentlemen
prefer blondes 2 starring the new it
girl carolyn monroe so is all of this
good is it bad honestly i don't love it
definitely makes me a bit uncomfortable
even without the deep fake faces
currently being stuck in the uncanny
valley it just feels ethically icky to
bring back stars and put words in their
mouth without their permission you know
regardless of how i feel though it's
absolutely a fact that it becomes much
easier for an individual's image to be
exploited in ways that they might not
have wanted it's actually something that
mandalorian producer john favreau seemed
keenly aware of in the behind the scenes
documentary for the series because it's
becoming harder and harder to tell fake
from real and if we know that we have
the technology that could address that
part of our responsibility is to keep an
eye on that and see how we can help um
maximize the benefit while uh
diminishing or eliminating the downside
but you have to think what happens when
these tech savvy ethically minded
artists are no longer in charge when
people like john favreau or kevin feige
move on from lucasfilms and marvel
studios we've already seen how quickly
the tone of a company can change when
someone new takes the reins just look at
the difference at disney under the
leadership of bob iger versus bob
chapeck tiger was famous for his
positive relationships with the talent
while jpeg has become infamous for
squabbling with the likes of scarlett
johansson over compensation if anyone is
in the position to exploit these dead
celebrities it's disney all throughout
these deep fake theories we've mentioned
how disney has been building a library
of photo scans of actors appearing in
the big franchises and sure for now they
seem to be asking the estates of the
stars for their input and permission
when they resurrect the characters or
getting talent like mark hamill involved
when they de-age luke skywalker with
deep fakes but who's to say they'll keep
doing that there doesn't seem to be
anything to legally stop them from using
these images long after they've died
without asking permission samuel l
jackson seems to think that that might
be an option suggesting that disney
could insert a digital stanley into
every movie they make from now until the
end of time and at the rates that
attitudes in both hollywood and the
general audience are changing if you
have the avengers assembling in the year
2150 from beyond the grave well that's
something that a lot of people would pay
to see but hey that's just a theory a
film theory and cuts
you